there's no instructions for this no no
it's just climb in balloon I've got my
leg in and it just seems painful can I
sleep in it for the water now how are
you feeling this
pull it over yourself
[Laughter]
hello I'm currently stood next to one of
the funniest things it's a six foot
balloon so then we got trying to get
further in it I wonder if you could
drown in there easily
[Applause]
I mean it's nice and refreshing you're
like damn Jabba the Hutt it's quite nice
job can't do anything by it yeah you
like a slug with need niche or my head
can't get it can you get it please
you're it yeah whereabouts unlike both
sides of my head like like the temple
area no no stick up a bit up oh but
loads of room in here now have you yeah
I can spread my let what was spread by
legs up joined put your head under
[Laughter]
it's nice in there yeah it's like a
human sized womb oh my box is on hey you
should take off your boxes so when you
come out it's already funny all right
I'm gonna play
[Music]
[Music]
well that was absolutely phenomenal I
think that should go into history it's
one of the greatest things ever shown
info was your face is you've been given
birth literally I was born again yeah
it was quite refreshing actually yeah
yeah a nice bit of sunshine I gotta say
ever since we did the original giant
balloon video I've always wondered what
it looked like if someone was inside I
looked online now I was just looking for
balloons and I saw climbing balloons I
was just like it is done it is diabetes
diet well hopefully if you enjoyed the
original you liked that one as well be
sure to follow us on Twitter buy a shirt
if you want Dan's not wear any oh don't
worry mine soon we are gonna be making a
shirt of just this Chester so look look
forward to okay cool and uh thank you so
much for watching we'll see you in the
next video